方針ビジョンしていいこと悪いことを
決める判断軸それは私が明確に出してます
それぞれ任された人がちゃんと計画を立て
て実行してるこれがアチーブメントなん
ですね責任感のない人間だなと思ったら
外します私は責任感のない人間には仕事は
任せません青木サの人生経営哲学100回
聞いたら豊かになる
話今回はですね部に仕事をせられない
マネージャーっていると思うんですけれど
もなんかどうしたら仕事を抱え込まずに
仕事化することができるのかっていうこと
についてメッセージいただけますでしょう
[音楽]
かそれはね物差し短い物差しでものを見る
のか長い物差しで見るかによって判断
変わるんだけれども人を育てなければその
仕事の上の仕事にはつけないじゃないだ
から人を育てるというのはフィールド
トレーニングって僕は言うんだけどね
やっぱり現場で実地の中から人は育って
いくのでその実地実施をしながら一緒に
仕事をしていくことが大事なんですよ任せ
ちゃいけないことは任しちゃだめなのよ実
はねうちはの採用に関してもうちの採用
チーム4人その採用だけを専念してる子が
いるんですよその上司がもちろんまた2人
ねその採用全体を見てるま6人ぐらいで今
採用チームやってるんだけど全部彼らが
考えてるんですよ僕何にも口出してない
ですよもう21年前から採用始まってるん
だけれども最初4大卒の子を採用の責任者
にしてその子に考えさせたんですよだって
僕貧しい家庭に育って早く社会出てるから
大学行ってないじゃん大学生の気持ち
なんてわかんねもん学生視点でもの考え
ないと学生が考える働きがってどんなもの
なのかは学生に考えてもらうのが1番いい
じゃんだから考えてもらってそして
アイデア出してもらってそっから採用
スタートしたわけだよねで今どうだろう
代々もう21年だからまある一定の期間
キャリア積むとみんな色々部署も変わるの
で今1番若い子たちが4人今頑張ってやっ
てくれてるけれども8代面ぐらいになるん
じゃないかなだんだんそうやってバトン
タッチしながらで年々クオリティも良く
なってるしやっぱり彼らに考えてもらって
彼らが
求める理想のアチーブメントってどういう
アチーブメントでどういう風にどういう
人材を採用したらこの会社の未来があるの
かっていうことを一緒に考えながら彼らが
企画した採用でうまく言っているだから何
でもかんでも自分でやらなきゃいけないと
思ったら僕はダメですよねそういう意味で
は時間もないしまず採用でしょ営業
マーケティングにしても橋本拓也ってのが
今責任者ですよ取締り営業本部長で全責任
持ってやってくれてますよ管理部門も
取締り管理本部長は高橋優ですよ高橋ゆが
全部管理門は責任持ってやってくれて私の
方はとま報告ただ方針ビジョンしていい
こと悪いことを決める判断軸それは私が
明確に出してますこれは私じゃなきゃでき
ない仕事だよねだから委任するにもこの
判断軸を明確にするつまりうちの場合は
企業理念我が者は選択理論を元にした高品
質の人材教育を通してて顧客の成果の想像
に貢献し全社員の物心両面の幸福の追求と
社会の平和と繁栄に寄与するこの3つの
目的これを上質の追求という言葉で表し
てる理念なんですよねつまり対顧客対社員
対社会この3つの輪の中心に理念があって
これを追求するということを全社員がそこ
を目指してるわけですよだこれに反する
仕事やこれと関係ないことをやることは
ないんですよ我々の事業というのは縁ある
人の人生の質の向上に寄与したいっていう
わけですからね選択理論では人の幸せて
いうのは5つの基本的欲求が満たされてる
状態というので生存愛と所属力ね自由
楽しみこの5つの
が満たされてる状態これが幸福であるなら
ばこのことのサポートをするのが事業なん
ですよという風に私はその方針だけは明確
に出してるけど実務は採用だとか営業だと
か管理だとか経理人事総務いろんな機能が
あるけどそれぞれ任された人がちゃんと
計画を立てて実行してるこれが
アチーブメントなんですよねそういうこな
んじゃないかなだから実行責任異人責任を
区分してやっぱり上に立つ人間は異人責任
を全頭しなきゃいけないんじゃないか実行
するのはやっぱり部下ですよと私は考えて
ますけどありがとうございます最初は全部
自分がやるっていうステージが誰しも通る
道だと思うんですけれども自分が全部やっ
てきたっていうところからなんか1番最初
に誰かに何かを任せるっていうことて何か
少しこうハードルがあるのかなっていう風
に思ったりするですけど青木社長ってこう
まご自分がすごくプレイヤーとして本当に
結果を作ってこられたところから最初に誰
かに何かを任せるとか異をしていくって
いうところてどうやってこう乗り越えてこ
られたんです
[音楽]
か絆奏して育ててるわけだよねで絆奏して
育てるので見ててしっかりとできるレベル
になったなとなった時に初めて任せて
るってことだ
知らない上司はだめですあと絆奏しない
人間もだめ口先だけでとか全部フィールド
トレです私はフィールド現場でそして見て
覚えさせて言って聞かせてやらせてみて
褒めてやらねば人は動かじと山本いさんも
言ってるけど私はもう現場型の経営者なの
で適性を見て任せるべき人間に任せますで
責任感のない人だなと思ったら外します私
は責任感のない人間には仕事は任せません
やり遂げる力これを持ってる人間に仕事は
任せますあとは画の強い人間は大きなミス
します素直で向上心があって
コミュニケーション能力のある人間は
大丈夫ですでも画の強い人間はね自分判断
しちゃうのよで上司の判断ではなく自分
判断を優先するのでこれは危ないんですよ
だからね大きな穴開けるのはね無能な人間
じゃなくてね思い込みの強い優秀な人間が
大きな穴開けのだからちゃんとそこは見
とかなきゃだめなんですで私は報告連絡
相談命令実施報告これものすごく厳しい
上司だと思いますうん私の秘書なんかは今
4人秘書がいるんだけど即し法のもく
フィードバック入るよあれ報告どうなった
あれはどうなった嫌なんですよなぜなら全
責任持ってるから責任者なので報告を
もらいたいんですよ僕はだじゃあ信頼して
ないから違います穴開けたくないだけです
どうしてお客さんに迷惑かけてるから人に
迷惑かけたくないんですよ僕はだから全部
を掌握したいんですだから今はねたった
まだ200人ぐらいの組織なのよでもま
300人ぐらいはともかく1挙1同速全部
は把握できてる状態任せてる人間が
ちゃんと下の報告を毎日のように私に重要
なことは判断を仰ぐし宗法がきちっと来る
し全部現場が分かってるあとはうちはもう
毎日例えば資金繰り表も経理から全部入り
ますしもう全て僕は掌握してます掌握の中
でみんな仕事をするそれが経営なんじゃ
ないのだから掌握できてない経営者って
規模大きくしちゃダメなんです10人とか
はま現場管理できるよねでもそれが30人
なってくる50人なってくる100人超え
てくるとなると自分の右腕左腕がしっかり
しなきゃなるですここのね幹部育てないで
もう欲ばっかりでどんどんどんどん拡張し
ちゃうと必ずボタンのけけ間違いが起きて
全部外してもう1回やりにやり直しをし
なきゃいけなくなるそういう傾斜いっぱい
見てきました出しちゃいけないところに
テポ出すとかね採用しちゃいけない人間
採用するとかねそれは全部ね我欲です原理
原則じゃないんですやっぱりちゃんとね
その人を見て報そして任せるべく人に
任せる任しちゃいけない人間に任せない
じゃどうしたらいいの自分がやるしかない
よってことはいつまでたっても組織大きく
できないってことだよいいじゃない別に
なんで組織と大きくしなきゃいけないのお
客さん中心にもの考えなさいとお客さん
から見て1番大切なのはクオリティですよ
量じゃないよそこの誠実さがあれば絶対
こけないよこける人間っていうのは不正実
なんですだ僕はねあのずるい人とか約束
破る人間とかもう口先の人間あんまり好き
じゃないよく見てます僕はちゃんと実効力
のある人間に仕事を任せてるんでま一応
アチーブメントが今ねおかげ様で38期目
に入りましたけど毎年きち業績が上がって
コロナの時でも初めて前年退避割ったけど
利益は6億その年も出しましたよそれは僕
が全部掌握してるからですというか現場の
人間が期待に答えようと頑張ってくれて
るってことだねまうちは本当に社員に守ら
れてますただその社員を選んだのは最終的
には役員人だからね役員面接で選んでるん
だから入れたら障害絶対自分から諦めない
私は絶対諦めません絶対諦めないなんで
自分の子供をね諦める親っていないじゃん
それぐらい愛情持って僕は社員大事にして
ますよ本当可愛いもん社員本音本心でうん
だ社員は駒じゃないんですよだから任せて
人は育つんですその責任は自分が取ら
なきゃいけないでもやってこらん最悪の時
は僕は全部最終的には責任持ってあげる
からまず実行してこらん恐れる必要ないよ
そういう愛情が大事なんじゃないのそう
思いますよ何かあっても僕が最終的に健康
である程度自分がそのなんて言うのかな
責任の持てる範囲であれば最後まで
やっぱりね大きな愛の中で社員って働く
わけじゃんある意味で包み込んでく愛が
大事なんじゃないでしょうかねそう思う
けどね愛がないと任せられないようんだっ
てもう失敗したくないんだもんでも失敗し
なかったらどうやって成長するのよ失敗
ってキャリアのことなんだよ経験を積んで
人は成長するんで痛みを経験せずに学習
できないじゃないだからあの私のね研究し
てきた中でダメな親ってね例えば運動1つ
にしてもね転ばせないようにするんですよ
子供だから運動能力めっちゃ低くなっ
ちゃうのよもうともかく自由にさしてね
転んだってね何があってもだんだん
だんだん学習してね成長してくんだよもう
社員もね同じですよその転ばせるある意味
で勇気と命を落としちゃだめだけどここ
まで見守るという器っていうのは上司には
必要なんじゃないかなまそんな風に思い
ますまだから一緒に仕事してるってこと
じゃないの結論は共に放置してるわけじゃ
ないから任せて任せずって言葉がある
じゃん任せてるけれどもそれやっぱり
チームの一員として仕事してるので何か
あったらいつでもサポートに出るという
体制なんじゃないのかなそういう意味では
ま人は任されて初めて責任を持って成長し
てく存在だと思いますよ私は考えてみたら
相当任せてるよねでも任せちゃいけないな
と思ったら降ります降りるってことは自分
が降りてちゃんとサポートしてあげ
るってことそこはもう無責任にはしません
それが大事なとこだと是非コメントお願い
しますそしてチャンネル登録も是非
よろしくお願いします
[音楽]
でも実際そうなんだようん任せない限り人
は成長しませんあのね痛みを
伴うなんだろう経験って成長には不可欠な
んですよ僕なんかもどれほどこけてきた
ことかだって鉄構所からさのし上がってく
のにチャレンジしないでね成長なんかない
もんどれだけ痛み経験したかだからその
たびに自分はねなんでこんなに人に迷惑を
かけちゃうダメな人間なんだろうって大
反省しましたよで反省して反省して反省し
て反省して明日はもっと良くなろう明日は
もっと良くなろうと思って一生懸命頑張っ
て今があるわけじゃん未だにそうだよ人間
なんかね完璧完全なかがないよだから寛大
管用人に対してもそういう姿勢を保た
なきゃだめなんですようんだからなんか
人間ってねなんだろうな不完全なんだけど
尊い存在であり不完全だからチームなん
ですよお互い助け合うんですよそしてまQ
っていうか円形のね形になるわけですよ
あんまりねなんだろう完全完璧を人にも
求めない方がいい僕なんかは社員に対して
も6割できたらま良しとするぐらいの
気持ちを持ちながら6割でもちゃんと報酬
が出せる会社の仕組みを整えようとそう
思って仕事をしてきましたそうじゃないと
完璧完全じゃないと今の職失うみたいにね
そんな状態ではチャレンジできないもん
だけでもいいよっていうぐらいので本人は
ベストを尽くすわけですよだからちょうど
いいんですよそれがうんあのリードタイム
も持てるし助け合えるじゃないですかそう
いうことだと思うようん